- He's yours.
- Ah.
- But you didn't even say anything.
- That's right, no winterns.
(audience laughs)
I played that perfectly and kept quiet.
And keeping quiet is not easy for me.
I mean, you guys know I'm not allowed back
into three movie theaters.
(audience laughs)
Kenney gets the hand off.
Oo, to the 10.
She's at the five.
She's got one man to beat and scores.
Touchdown!
(audience cheers)
- Well, I guess that answers the question
of whether Carols still has her real hips.
(laughing)
(applauding)
- All right, what's up?
I'm back with Patricia Heaton, y'all.
(audience cheers)
That was a clip from her
new show, Carol's Second Act
which airs Thursdays on CBS.
So you say your life kinda mirrors Carol,
it mirrors Carol's a bit right?
- Yeah 'cause her kids
are out of the house.
My kids are out of the house.
She's embarking on this
new adventure as a doctor.
She used to be a high
school science teacher.
She's divorced so she's
reframing her life.
It's new for me in the
sense that I'm first time
exec producing the show
and there's a lot of
responsibilities that come with that.
- Yeah.
- And it's good 'cause
it's challenging me.
I am kind of stress dreams.
Where I'll be like in a
house that I'm remodeling
and I don't know if it's working
and it's costing a lot of money and I know
that's like a reflection
of trying to build a show.
- Yes.
- You know, like can I do this?
Is it gonna look good?
So it's good though,
keeps your brain going.
- Active, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- No I'm the same way, I've
never done anything like this.
- Right, it's a lot.
- It's a whole different
level of pressure.
(laughs)
- Right.
- I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
- That's vodka in here, just
in case you're wondering.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- But you are raising, this is crazy
and I can't believe I didn't know this
'cause that's an injustice for how hard
you must have been working,
but you raised four toddlers while doing
Everybody Loves Raymond?
- The first season of Raymond,
I had a three year old,
a one year old and I was
pregnant with the third.
And then the third season I had my fourth.
All c-sections.
And I don't know how,
because now working on Carol
with no kids at home, I'm exhausted.
How I did it with four kids.
I used to get up in the morning
and my first thought was,
"I could really use a beer right now".
(laughs)
Just thinking about
getting through the day.
- Just a tiny bit.
- And when I got home, you
know I'd get the boys to bed.
I'd pour a big glass
of red wine, you know.
- Yes, I do.
- And one night, I was drinking the wine
and my son Joe called me back upstairs
so I ran up, I leaned down and
I said, "What is it honey?"
And he just looked at me, he said,
"Mom you smell like communion".
(laughs)
It's 'cause I go down there
and pray for you boys every night.
- I'm such a good mom.
(laughing)
I used to love communion
'cause I'd be starving during
church and they'd pass
out those little crackers,
and I'm like, I didn't
feel the Lord enough,
just one more, just little more.
(laughing)
You weren't supposed to,
I'm probably going to hell,
it's fine.
So where are your sons these days?
- So, the two oldest are in Nashville.
- [Kelly] Yes, you were
just talking about that.
- Yeah, so my oldest
son is in a band called
Forest Fire Gospel
Choir, they're very good.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But he also works at Adele's.
Did you ever eat at Adele's?
- Yeah, yeah.
- The second one is still
living there also, just working.
Third one's here in L.A.
Fourth one is at The Ohio State
University, my alma mater.
- Oh that's exciting.
- Do we have any
Buckeye's here?
O-H, O-H?
(audience member whoos)
- Not one.
- I-O.
You have to say I-O.
Okay not a single Buckeye.
- Anybody love Texas?
Anybody?
(cheers)
Okay, there we go.
- Yeah, so we're adjusting but it's great.
I love when they come home, yeah.
- That's fun though.
I always feel like my husband's
looking forward to it.
We have a three year old and
he's still looking forward
to it.
- Oooo.
- [Kelly] Like he's like
it's gonna be so exciting.
- Three is a wonderful
age and boys are just--
- It is a threenager though,
but yeah that's our boy.
- He's a threenager?
- Yeah, we call it.
Two's were fine, three's
are the devil has actually
come inside their body
and I need an exorcist.
- So you're drinking
communion every night?
- I drink a lot of communion.
(laughs)
It wasn't my fault.
Jesus changed that water into wine.
He taught us correctly.
Yes, I only need water.
Are you bothering them to
have grandkids yet, though
because now they're out of the house?
- Oh yes and in fact,
I do it nationally like
every talk show I go on, okay
what camera should I look in?
This one right here, okay boys,
I'm just letting you know,
the first one that gives me
a grandchild gets the house.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
- I just got them all outta the house
and now I want more back in.
- I know, I want more kids.
My husband doesn't,
it's super interesting.
(laughs)
Speaking of kids, tell us about
your work with World Vision.
You do a lot of work with them.
- Yeah, and that's a lot apart
of my second act I think.
The biggest provider of
clean water in the world
and they started the sponsorship program
where you can sponsor a child
but they've done this cool new thing now
called Chosen.
And it's $39 a month but
instead of World Vision
just sending you a picture
of a child and saying,
would you like this child,
you send your picture to World Vision
and they take it into a community
and they put all the pictures
up and the child picks you.
(audience awws)
And then you get a letter
from the child telling you
why they picked you.
It's really rewarding,
it's really exciting.
- And consistency with one person.
- [Patricia] That's right.
- I think that's so, kids,
I mean you know this better
than anyone with four kids
but they need consistency.
- Well and I've traveled
a lot with World Vision.
To Zambia, Jordan, Uganda,
Rwanda and you know,
people are the same everywhere.
I was traveling with one
of the World Vision workers
from Rwanda and you're in
the car for a long time.
He was telling me about
having to go home that weekend
and go to the wedding of
one of his wife's coworkers.
And he was complaining
'cause like I don't know
any of these people at her office.
- It's like what happens at home.
- I'm like, it doesn't
matter if you're in Africa
or the U.S., like marriage
is the same everywhere.
- No one wants to go to
the office Christmas party.
I'm just kidding, ours
is gonna be awesome guys.
(laughs)
- But I think it just shows you,
how we're really all the same everywhere
and this World Vision Chosen program
is a great way to connect.
- Has your child picked
you yet for World Vision?
- No, I have not heard of
who my child is yet, yes.
- [Kelly] Okay, that's so interesting.
- Yeah, I'm waiting too.
- Well, we asked World Vision
for the video of your child,
would you like to see
who chose you?
- Oh you have it?
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- Yes, let's take a look.
(audience applauds)
(in foreign language)
(peaceful music)
(audience applauds)
- That was so sweet.
- And I love little boys.
Okay, I don't need a
grandchild right away.
- He picked you and said your smile was--
- Oh my God.
- Oh my gosh,
that was so sweet.
That was really special.
- That's amazing.
- You guys, we all gotta do
that, that was so special.
- It's a great thing to
do as a Christmas gift
to yourself.
You get a lot more back.
- My mother does that at Christmas.
She'll give us, like I
bought a cow for this family.
- That's right, World Vision has a catalog
where if you can't sponsor a child,
maybe just, you can buy
chickens for a family.
- She does that, my mama.
- Yes they share it
with the rest of the village.
It's a gift that keeps on giving.
It's wonderful.